hello rejects this is greg album win
hope James I'm talking now that was
weird yep we just saw the seven nycc
trailer of The Walking Dead and we
wanted to give you know some speculation
and our theory as to who we think negan
actually killed in the end I know Glen
is the one who dies in the comic which I
just learned cuz I haven't read the
comics at all but I was shocked yeah his
brains on the horns I ball passes brains
what I'm going to say is in the death
scene when they when they die whoever it
is I hope it's just as violent as that I
know you're not big fan of violence but
I really wanted to be super viola cos
like you know bashing up a walker is one
thing but how disturbing would it be if
they did it to human i think i would
only add to the impact of negan if we
see like something as grotesque as that
more than just brains were like oh my
god his eyeball is like hanging out and
like it's just that [ __ ] up I'm not
like violence oh really yeah and now
we're just gonna seventh season in the
walking dead I know but funny a violence
in walking dead I close my eyes you're
missing out but still am I for fans like
myself I think it should be super
grotesque super violent but who do I
actually think was that part of me
thinks okay I could see why they would
go with Glenn because they killed him
off earlier in the season in season six
but then they brought him back which was
kind of a cop-out for a lot of people
yeah it was a cop out for me cuz I was
like really that's I mean I guess I
could kind of believe it is I want him
to be alive and yeah I didn't like how
he died cuz it was like that's the way
you kill uncle n so i guess it was good
they brought him back but if they're
really gonna like honor that a no or I
can see them going you know what the
fans were upset that we brought him back
so let's let's really do this right and
really show no he's dead for real those
not like a wolf zombie or someone
meat-eating on top of him are being beat
I'll talk to him like he is really dead
this time but wasn't ok I don't know the
comics
didn't Carol died early on and they kept
her because yeah but the thing is the
scene though yeah we're negan speech and
stuff is and the end like that blood
dripping from the first person point of
view that shot yeah that's in the comic
to it seem like they're being like
closer to the comic more than they
usually are for this particular moment
is in this moment they're gonna be like
[ __ ] this is in the comics yeah exactly
exactly they're gonna like throw you and
then you're already invested so you're
gonna keep watching here's who I don't
think it should be who I don't think it
should be Rick um Paul Emsley yeah I
don't think it should be any of the
smaller characters I think it has to be
a major character yeah we need to leave
people the room to die yeah and there's
characters that are not as popular as
loved like Rosita hey brihan Abraham
Aaron Eugene Sasha so for me it has to
be either Daryl Maggie Carl or Michelle
true Glenn obviously good but I think it
I think you should definitely be between
Maggie Daryl Carl I'm Michelle okay okay
so I mean who would you pick out of the
four of those like four or five major
characters cuz i know you earlier you
said you want to be kind of want to rick
to die but the trailer clearly shows
yeah word up I love Darrell so I kind of
want to keep him forever yes so I don't
think I don't want him to go but imagine
how heartbroken I would be if they
killed him but Darrell is a fan favorite
who is not in the comics he was in
videos ridden for the show so I can see
them justify why he's the major
character they killed off Oh see I would
love it if they killed Darrell because I
would hate it so much yeah we would hate
it we'd be heartbroken but I could still
see the show continuing on without
Darrell yeah even though he's like
[ __ ] awesome and he is a necessity to
the group I can still see them making it
work without Maggie Magdalene loves to
cry so the whole season he could just
cry the whole season over Maggie and you
brought up a good point before we film
how they probably don't want to deal
with another woman being pregnant and
nothing dealing with another baby they
already got uh what's the baby's name
Judith yeah chewed it yeah
so nailed it there we have to deal with
Judith I don't think they want to deal
with another we've already seen like the
pregnancy thing go and like it's fine
I'm a woman we can deal with it but
honestly I'm not interested in watching
a pregnant woman cuz that's way too
stressful again and Maggie was already
like really sick in the line the last
episode the side of the sixth season and
they were like they were traveling
trying to find a place to get medicine
for her so I could see them just like
finally doing it and just killing her
and like how cool like kill this sweet
beautiful you have a sweet pregnant
woman oh that means something make it
personal for Glenn and I could see Glenn
in the end even the being the one who
gets to kill negan so instead of like
like totally flipping it it would be
cool in the comics negan kills blood and
the show negan kills Maggie but then
Glenn eventually kills me like I can see
that work either way I mean I love
Maggie though I love watching her I
think she's great yeah so I'd be really
sad but story wise i think i'm gonna go
Maggie even though he only wanted to see
Carl's oh yeah there's Carl to ya Laurel
I don't know why they don't kill off
Carl he's like he's been like Ashton
killed off for like many seasons now a
lot of people just don't like him what I
think is cool about the at replace Carl
is at first I didn't like him first few
seasons in the first really it's kind of
swapping that's weird because I grew to
like him over the last few seasons but
before I did for me thinking about negan
I don't think he would kill Carl because
I think he would want to shatter Rick's
image in front of his son cuz right now
negan seems all about just scary [ __ ]
up the leadership in Rick's group i'm
just starting with rick like he kills
that the person if I Ricky's costly
taunting Rick it kind of seems like he
might sexually assault Rick when he
takes him into the RV I could see me and
being the kind of do that and then like
having a sun be witness to something
like this like I could see in going that
sadistic with it so that's why I don't
think it's Carl yeah I don't think it's
Carl so I would guess it's and actually
heard a theory a couple days ago that
with the footage of the release of my CC
the way the blood splatter is they think
that it looks like it could have come
from Rick's right side and Maggie was on
his right so it's probably Maggie so
yeah and so I think it could be
Maggie so that's my who we think it is
who do I want to see you killed oh no
mine too much handle my buck their help
I would want Michonne to die and get rid
of that I'm just not a fan of that
character really I never happened to me
she's always been cool girl with a sword
other than that I just don't think she's
that interesting of a carrot they've
gone into her backstory yeah it's cool
that you got it sorted you know how to
use it in drop off zombies heads anytime
they try like developing her more or
make her more like human cuz I know him
when they first introduced her she's
very closed off and he like has his
guard up all the time and now she's way
more vulnerable and you know really
connects with Carl's and having sex with
Rick and I feel like that would be a
great thing to do to Rick too because
he's just like starting to fall in love
him as shown that's my girl yeah kills
off Michonne I think Michonne is to me
has been not as not that interesting of
a character for aldi season I which is
weird because to a lot of people she's a
fan favorite he's the one who obvious
would like I didn't see why you say that
because she she's cool to look at and
she's cool to watch when she's killing
walkers but nothin she's not doing that
I just don't find her that interesting
Rick and Carol and Daryl I like all of
them I find way more interesting when
they're not killing walkers
significantly more Michonne I just think
she's style and not much substance I
originally wanted to combat that but I
really don't have a good defense for her
do you fence whoo yeah make the kill up
one of the minor characters it's just a
cop Aaron yeah like da like aaron just
showed up so he could me yeah just so
they get we need another person lineup
is time yeah there's a lot of these
people just seem like fillers but
because the thing is this needs to be a
major character death this needs to be
someone who's very hard breaking
something that really motivates stay
invested yeah Maggie's look Maggie seems
like the perfect choice is it like based
on everything we've been shown based off
the way things have been set up it seems
like Maggie would be the perfect choice
it Maggie does I'll be disappointed and
I say all that they flipped it because
the first thing had you believe early in
the season that Glenn's the one who died
and then you see Maggie are heartbroken
and she's pregnant that would be cool to
flip that like oh she's the one who
actually
at the end of the season of one so I
think it'd be a great way to you know
like reverse things in terms for fans of
the comics and people who know the
source material yeah but I don't think
they're gonna do it I just I would have
wanted miss shown to be the one who gets
killed but you need your black character
and you need your asian character so
they're gonna keep Darryl keeps not dear
okay keep gonna Michelle and glide on
there so cuz you need yeah multi races
yeah they think he'd use like a strong
Mexican character isn't that Rashida
that was might have been really stupid
to say that might have just been racist
or accurate I'm sorry white girl you
need to be careful of your words we got
Sasha she's black I'm done with this is
Glenn like the only asian guy in this
universe like there's like no other
Asian people anyway that's our
prediction we think it's Maggie I mean
who Jim we agreed we agreed on who we
believe it's going to be I say Michelle
for who I wanted out who would you have
wanted to die excluding Rick right
really ah you're just like I'm Maggie
yeah okay okay come on Maggie yeah well
not cheap I deserves it that that poor
family has just suffered Maggie's like
whole family oh really suffered not
gonna lie I was really happy when her
dad died what every way that was so sad
is great widget wait when the governor
actually did that I was like it was so
sad because he only got like half of his
next slice lobster he was crawling for a
while yeah oh no hope Oh anyway guys
thanks for tuning in to our little
conversation piece we really put a lot
of thought into it about five minutes of
preparation with more than I normally do
wow you're new to this channel subscribe
today become rejected and you can follow
home apparently thing this is what I'm
like weirdly randomly uncomfortable I
thought you had like rejected I'm not
the most comfortable saying like you
know some YouTube line when I know it's
a YouTube line I could see that
yeah so I do like weird body much if you
just accept that it's cheesy and tell
him it's cheesy like hey guys this is
cheesy but do it because it helps me in
life yeah subscriber day become a reject
marketing hope I'm cool the series com
where she is it's based off her life
it's a biographical drama piece being
uncool in Los Angeles California I think
I should pitch for you I could be your
producer manager I think I know what I'm
doing and you follow her on Twitter 20
another YouTube question who do you
think will die